but in a weird way also why we're acting
why we're actors
it's not just about the affirmation
they're also occasionally opportunities
when you're given amazing things to say
that speak to your truth the truth that
maybe you've been searching for
knowingly or maybe unknowingly you know
so that if you're it sounds highfalutin
if you're doing Shakespeare and you're
saying something absolutely gorgeous and
pithy
it and and if you connect to it it's
incredibly meaningful and it kind of
kicks a there's a moment of growth that
happens in you which you know actually
leads me into the kind of the the uh wga
being on strike you know the writers how
necessary they are to this process to
our creative process as actors and also
as an audience how how much audiences
need pithy thought out well-constructed
dialogue and Concepts and you know as
actors haven't you found moments of of
great emotional Clarity in a part that
you've been that you've been that you've
learned where you're able to say
something to somebody in ways that
you've never been able to say in real
life or have somebody a character touch
you physically and and and and you know
um and intellectually and emotionally in
ways that the people around you in real
life have been too hell held were too
afraid to express there's something
amazingly I don't know uh basic about it
yeah